est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus sur l'importance pour vous de
cette élection sénatoriale tout le monde
sait que l'élection sénatoriale cette
année revêt un caractère particulier
c'est juste après l'élection
présidentielle mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas de vagues comme on
dit qui se produit après chaque élection
présidentielle lorsque l'élection
législative se produit à moi après il y
aura donc sans doute un rééquilibrage là
il s'agit des grands électeurs par
rapport aux équilibres que l'on connaît
à l'Assemblée nationale pourquoi c'est
important d'abord c'est important
d'avoir des parlementaires qui vous
représentent bien qui représente la
sensibilité politique la diversité
politique et aussi les territoires c'est
très important de le rappeler mais c'est
aussi important pour la France parce que
si le président de la République
souhaite modifier la Constitution il a
annoncé déjà un certain nombre de
réformes le cumul des mandats dans le
temps la limitation du commune des mains
d'A dans le temps la réduction du nombre
de parlementaires députés et sénateurs
pour ça il faut réformer la Constitution
il faut donc avoir une majorité des 3/5
donc selon ce qui sortira
de ce vote au Sénat et bien ça sera un
éclairage pour ce qui se passera
éventuellement lors de la réforme
constitutionnelle
sénatorial des élus souvent inquiets sur
l'avenir des collectivités territoriales
oui c'est sûr que cette élection c'est
notoriale prend une dimension qui est
celle des territoires c'est d'abord une
élection des territoires les grandes
villes les villes moyennes les petites
communes donc c'est la diversité de la
France qui s'exprime à travers ce vote
et manifestement il s'agit d'un délude
pour la plupart d'entre eux qui sont
électeurs ils vont exprimer certainement
une inquiétude sur l'avenir des
collectivités locales les réformes
territoriales mais aussi surtout les
finances des collectivités locales c'est
parfaitement légitime